[Musique]
politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 épisode 243 ce
soir mon invité et la députée des
Yvelines Natalia pouzi F
[Musique]
au politique
Natalia poussi rêve bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous alors on va
revenir longuement avec vous ce soir sur
les questions liées au secteur de la
défense vous êtes donc député
renaissance de la 6ème circonscription
des Yvelines avant cela vous avez
travaillé pendant 25 ans dans
l'industrie aéronautique 17 ans à Thalès
8 ans chez Airbus où vous lancez en
politique en 2016 et en même temps donc
que la création du parti en marche
d'Emmanuel Macron vous êtes élu député
en 2017 et réélu en 2022 vous êtes
aujourd'hui membre de la commission de
la Défense nationale des forces armées
de l'Assemblée nationale revenons
d'abord avant parler de tous ces sujets
sur votre engagement personnel qu'est-ce
qui vous a motivé à rejoindre le parti
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2016 mais c'était
l'offre politique que j'attendais depuis
longtemps parce que effectivement on
prône le le dépassement des clivages et
pour une politique pragmatique qui
consiste à transformer le pays là où il
en a besoin alors ça c'est pas
facilement la vue récemment ça se fait
parfois dans la douleur mais c'était
voilà la conviction que peut-être que je
pouvais contribuer à mon modèle ce
niveau à cette à cet élan car moi je
suis convaincue que il faut que nous
puissions
réformer notre pays justement pour les
générations futures si vous voulez ma
carrière elle est un peu derrière moi
mais mon engagement à la base de mon
engagement il y a ce sentiment de
responsabilité pour l'intérêt général et
notamment pour les jeunes générations et
on sait qu'on a beaucoup de défis à
relever il y a des enjeux de sécurité
mais il y a aussi le climat il y a
beaucoup bien sûr de de défis qui nous
attendent et que l'on a compte sur
lesquels on a commencé qu'on commençait
à construire une carrière Renault
nautique vous êtes ensuite spécialisé
donc à l'Assemblée nationale sur les
questions de défense pourquoi ce choix
c'était logique pour vous de vous
spécialiser dans ce secteur oui alors on
creuse certains sillons dans sa vie et
parfois on pense qu'on va y échapper et
finalement
ah je crois que c'est logique
personnelle dans laquelle on s'inscrit
et tout ça est assez cohérent et comme
dans mon passé c'était l'aéronautique la
défense bien sûr donc la commission de
la défense était toute à titré mais il y
avait aussi l'aspect coopération
internationale c'est là où j'ai passé
même si je suis de formation interne
ingénieur c'est là où j'ai passé le plus
de temps en fait à l'international et
donc les questions d'Europe de la
défense de voir comment on pouvait
construire des partenariats
et des ponts entre nos parlements
nationaux et a toujours été assez
centrale alors les relations entre
Emmanuel Macron et l'armée avait
commencé de manière mouvementée en tout
cas on peut on peut le dire avec la
démission du général Pierre de de
Villiers la raison de la démission
c'était il souhaitait dénoncer la baisse
du budget des armées alors avec le recul
et donc cette nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire aujourd'hui qui
explosent si je dis un qui augmente
énormément le budget de l'armée ce que
le général Pierre de Villiers avait
raison en 2017 de pousser ce coup de
gueule alors le général De Villiers a
fait une alerte c'était pas sur le passé
puisqu'on venait effectivement de
période où la défense n'avait pas connu
de réels augmentation mais lorsqu'il est
arrivé au pouvoir Emmanuel Macron s'est
engagé à avoir une loi de programmation
qui allait rehausser le budget fortement
notamment avec des marches à 3 milliards
et c'est ce qu'a mis c'est le futur
c'est l'avenir que le général Pierre de
Villiers a mis en question en disant oui
oui ça c'est je veux pas qu'on me
raconte en fait des fariboles il faudra
les tenir et le président a mis un acte
d'autorité parce qu'il a dit non moi je
m'engage là dessus et effectivement la
tenue donc le général Pierre de Villiers
a eu tort puisque on est parti de 3,2
32 pardon,7 milliards de budget annuel
de défense en 2017 pour les forces
armées donc euh et maintenant nous
sommes à 44 en 2023 44 milliards donc il
y a eu des marches d'abord à 1 milliard
7 et là on est sur des marches donc des
progressions annuelles de 3 milliards
donc les engagements tous les
engagements ont été tenus à l'Europe par
le Président de la République par le
ministère la ministre des Forces armées
qui étaient Florence Parly et maintenant
par Sébastien Lecornu qui va respecter
aussi ses engagements qui va donc
proposer cette nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire le gouvernement
espère la votée autour du 14 juillet
cette date forcément symbolique pour le
secteur des armées alors ce projet de
loi cette loi de programmation militaire
il fixe les elle fixe les orientations
de la politique de défense pour les
prochaines années donc là ce seront les
années de 2024 à 2030 qui seront
concernés donc pour cette prochaine
année un budget de 413 milliards d'euros
seront consacrés aux dépenses militaires
c'est une augmentation donc la
précédente loi pour la période 2019-2025
elle avait pour budget 295 un milliard
d'euros on serait donc si elle a adopté
sur une augmentation de 118 milliards
d'euros sur sur cette année un effort
conséquent pourquoi sur six années
pardon un effort conséquent pourquoi
est-ce que c'est primordial aujourd'hui
de d'augmenter ce budget des forces
armées alors déjà il y a eu un saut
quantitatif notable sur la précédente
LPM pour réparer nos armées nous avions
nous avons toujours une armée d'emplois
et nous avions des forces engagées comme
vous le savez au Sahel avec des
matériels qui s'usent beaucoup mais
aussi des hommes qui sucent beaucoup et
un taux d'activités un taux d'emploi en
fait qui était très élevé et qui ne
permettait pas toujours l'entraînement
des hommes sur les machines aussi il
faut avoir une armée véritablement
opérationnelle et donc pour cela il
fallait réparer à la fois les matériels
et permettre aux à nos soldats de
s'entraîner dans les meilleures
conditions possibles aussi
donc ça c'est la première étape et
depuis bien sûr le 24 février de l'année
dernière nous avons une guerre aux
portes de l'Europe les menaces ont
changé donc même si on nous avions
anticipé l'instabilité qui règne dans
les différentes régions du monde j'ai
parlé de l'Afrique mais il y a aussi
l'un d'opacifique il y a toujours des
menaces qui peuvent venir du Sud par des
proxy des groupes terroristes il ne faut
pas l'oublier mais en plus on a cette
attaque qui a lancé la Russie sur le
crâne donc il a fallu revoir
à la lumière de ces événements bien sûr
les moyens les capacités qu'il fallait
renforcer qu'il fallait adapter alors il
faut savoir que pour un conflit de haute
intensité peut-être que celui dans celui
dans lequel l'Ukraine est engagé face à
la Russie si jamais ce conflit arrivé en
Europe ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui disons s'il concernait des
pays de l'Union européenne on serait
forcément
appelé à intervenir en coalition mais
nous n'en sommes pas là en revanche la
France veut pouvoir avoir sa
souveraineté aussi avoir ses capacités
de déployer son armée partout elle le
veut quand elle le veut donc pour ça il
faut pouvoir préparer pas la guerre
d'aujourd'hui mais la guerre de demain
qui sera beaucoup basée sur
qui se développera dans tous les
nouveaux champs et basé dans les
nouveaux domaines donc le cyber le
quantique le spatial donc là il faut
avoir non seulement une armée qui est
bien préparée opérationnellement des
capacités cohérentes avec les scénarios
de menaces
potentiels et investir tous les nouveaux
domaines technologiques parce que c'est
de là qui arrivent les ruptures et si
nous ne savons pas les anticiper et vous
voulez ça ne sert à rien d'aligner du
matériel c'est pour ça que l'on dit dans
cette nouvelle LPM on privilégie la
cohérence à la masse
parce que il faut pouvoir être en mesure
non seulement d'aligner du matériel mais
avoir surtout des équipes bien formées
des hommes bien formés des matériels en
condition opérationnelles donc c'est
pour ça qu'il y a beaucoup d'argent
aussi dans le maintien la maintenance
des matériels la logistique et également
d'avoir toutes les capacités
technologiques de pointes qui permettent
la plus grande connectivité possible
entre les satellites et toutes les
plateformes avions bâtiments troupeau
sol ça partout ou que l'on soit sur la
planète il y a un gros effort aussi sur
le renseignement qui est fait parce que
le renseignement ça nous donne quoi en
fait le renseignement ça nous donne la
capacité d'appréhender une situation par
nous-mêmes de ne pas être seulement sous
la gouttière de ce que dirait certains
pays une différence déco de chaque pays
exactement donc on a la capacité
d'apprécier une situation et de cette
capacité d'appréciation on en tire la
capacité de décision finalement alors
dans le cadre de l'étude de cette future
loi de programmation militaire vous avez
avec la commission de défense de
l'Assemblée nationale auditionnée le
chef d'état-major de l'armée le général
Thierry burqar est aussi le ministre de
la Défense Sébastien Lecornu quelles
étaient leurs
chefs
c'est priorité et quel est l'état de
l'armée dont il a fait part et bien
l'armée reste toujours une armée
d'emploi avec un modèle qui reste
complet
la phrase
de de du chef d'état-major des armées
c'est toujours
c'est prévenir la guerre avant la guerre
finalement et donc on est toujours cette
sur cette logique là les confrontations
se multiplient
un peu partout mais avant d'arriver à
l'affrontement il faut pouvoir être
capable de faire des escalader les
tensions et les conflits donc pour ça il
faut des capacités comme j'ai dit de
renseignements il faut des capacités de
détection il faut pouvoir allier la
dissuasion je dirais conventionnelle
c'est à dire qu'on peut on doit toujours
garder la priorité c'est de garder la
capacité d'entrer en premier dans un
théâtre d'opération donc c'est à dire
que on peut envoyer nos avions nos
rafales
sur un théâtre sans qu'il soit détruit
par les forces ennemies cette capacité
d'entrer en premier est très importante
et permettre d'avoir éventuellement des
actions de rétorsion très ciblées pour
faire une désescalade et puis sinon
notre doctrine reste toujours basée sur
la dissuasion la dissuasion nucléaire et
là nous avons des investissements
conséquents chaque année pour pouvoir
maintenir le niveau de de notre force
stratégique nucléaire qui est maritime
et qui est aéroportée aussi puis il y a
ce nouveau porte-avion qui fait beaucoup
parler il doit remplacer donc le
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle il devrait
être opérationnel en 2038 ça a été acté
par le ministre de la Sébastien Lecornu
le nouveau navire pèsera donc 75000
tonnes d'acier fera 350 mètres de long
et 80 mètres de large un budget de plus
de 5 milliards d'euros devrait être
consacré à sa réalisation certains
estiment qu'on pouvait s'en passer c'est
pas votre avis et bien justement comme
le disait le chef d'état-major et comme
le dit aussi le ministre le ministre
Sébastien Lecornu qui est très sensible
à la l'amplitude de notre zone
économique vous savez que nous avons
grâce aux outre-mer une une présence
déjà la France du deuxième domaine
maritime mondial exactement une présence
dans l'océan Indien dans l'océan
Pacifique et nous avons donc aussi une
responsabilité de protection par rapport
à nos compatriotes
ultramarins
le porte-avion permet de projeter des
forces c'est ça première capacité et
vous pouvez justement intervenir
rapidement si c'est nécessaire et quand
je disais cette capacité d'entrer en
premier vous l'avez d'autant plus elle
est d'autant plus favorable lorsque vous
projetez un avion depuis un
porte-avion mais aussi le porte-avion à
cet effet dissuasif aussi quand un avion
navigue en mer Méditerranée en
Méditerranée orientale tout le monde
sait qu'il est là tout le monde fait
attention enfin ceux qui voudraient
chercher à déstabiliser ou poursuivre
des trafics illicides d'amour est bien
sûr est en alerte et enfin troisième
chose c'est un outil européen puisque le
porte-avion peut agréger différentes
marines partenaires et en général il ne
sort pas seul mais on y a toujours les
frégates de surveillance de défense
qu'il entoure il est accompagné d'un
sous-marin nucléaire d'attaque également
donc c'est tout un écosystème c'est
toute une plateforme qu'on appelle le
groupe aéronaval nucléaire donc le
c'est un tout un groupe qui se projette
et vous pouvez à cela
agréger des frégates
italiennes des frégates néerlandaises
mais aussi du Royaume-Uni ce n'est pas
seulement limité aux partenaires
européens et cela permet à la France ce
groupe donc aéronavale de tenir par
exemple en Méditerranée orientale comme
je disais le rôle de nations cadre au
sein de l'OTAN puisque vous ne pouvez
qu'avoir une nation 4 ne peut ne peut
être nation4 que si elle a une certaine
force donc ce porte-avion nous permettra
sans nul doute de conserver notre rang
de puissance et d'assumer se rendre
puissance que nous avons puisque vous
savez faisons partie des cinq membres
permanents du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU donc ce porte-avion nous permettra
de garder ce rang de puissance et de
jouer notre rôle avec nos partenaires
européens au sein de l'OTAN méditer ée
orientale mais aussi de façon je dirais
purement national pour naviguer partout
où la liberté de navigation doit doit
être garantie on va passer maintenant la
deuxième partie de l'off de politique on
va parler de l'Ukraine la Russie et de
l'OTAN
[Musique]
toujours avec Natalia pouzirev député de
la sixième circonscription des Yvelines
et membre de la commission de la Défense
de l'Assemblée nationale la situation en
Ukraine se stabilise les observateurs
parlent donc d'une contre-offensive qui
pourrait advenir dans les prochains
jours l'Ukraine a été des fortement par
les États occidentaux depuis le début de
la guerre des États-Unis sont de loin
les premiers donateurs avec plus de
61,28 milliards d'euros annoncés la
France va nous étions à plus d'un 75
milliards d'euros d'aide début mars
est-ce que vous avez l'espoir que cette
contre-offensive puisse changer le cours
de cette guerre Natalia poussiéreff
alors cette offensive elle est annoncée
effectivement depuis un certain temps et
je pense que les Ukrainiens attendent
l'envoi de matériel nouveau et moderne
que les chars qui ont été promis
arrivent nous nos amis sont arrivés sur
le sur le terrain ils attend plus de
matériel aussi de défense aériennes et
donc c'est à eux de juger bien sûr
qu'elle sera le meilleur moment pour
mener cette contrepensive après
on espère qu'elle sera décisive sinon le
risque est que le conflit ne s'enlise et
ne s'éternise donc je crois que c'est
pour ça que l'Ukraine continue à faire
pression en disant c'est le moment ils
font pression sur les les pays alliés
pour leur dire c'est le moment de nous
envoyer le plus de matériel on a besoin
aussi de former nos soldats donc la
France vous savez c'est engagé à former
6000 soldats on en a déjà formé
plusieurs centaines voire quelques
milliers mais tout ça ça veut dire que
il faut attendre que le que les que les
forces armées soient prêtes c'est
toujours la même question de la
préparation opérationnelle c'est que les
matériels soient là qui sont en bonne
condition et que les les soldats soient
soient formés et ils déclencheront la
contre-offensive quand ils seront prêts
moi j'espère qu'elle sera décisive mais
ce n'est pas assuré puisque que chaque
côté va déployer sa propre tactique et
il y a peu de de je dirais d'options
pour véritablement déstabiliser la
Russie parce que si on veut une fin du
conflit rapide on va pas demander aux
Ukrainiens de déposer les armes eux ils
ont été envahis donc on va les soutenir
pour que les forces armées russes se
retirent mais pour qu'elles le fasse il
faut qu'elle subisse une défaite qui
n'est pas si pas une défaite majeure
mais quand même je pense qu'il faut
employer ce mot une défaite qui à un
moment donné les frères réfléchir et
peut-être les amènera à négocier en
étant dans un voilà avec un rapport de
force qui sera plus favorable à
l'Ukraine vous êtes Natalia pouzirev
présidente du groupe France Russie à
l'Assemblée nationale cette guerre en
Ukraine a énormément dégradé les
relations entre nos deux pays la Russie
a récemment révisé sa doctrine étrangère
elle qualifie l'Occident de menaces
existentielles le pouvoir russe aff que
la politique de l'Occident vise à
affaiblir la Russie par tous les moyens
quel est votre vision pour le futur des
relations franco-russes est-ce que il y
a une certaine fatalité à un
affrontement si on en croit donc les les
messages de du pouvoir russe non il y a
pas de fatalité à les fondements ce
message russe il est destiné à ses
propres populations ces véritablement de
la propagande qui leur est destiné pour
dire voyez nous nous sommes les victimes
et c'est la Russie qui est attaquée par
par l'Occident or tout le monde le
reconnaît c'est bien la Russie qui est
l'agresseur mais c'est un message qui
est destiné à ces populations pour leur
faire comprendre le prix du sacrifice
parce que les familles sacrifient quand
même beaucoup de leur fils et famille
russe et il faut que la population
l'accepte et donc le gouvernement du
Kremlin enfin le Kremlin veille à
maintenir la population de toute façon
sur le boisseau il nous lui délivre les
informations que les informations
qu'elle veut qu'ils entendent donc une
espèce de victimisation et c'est
justement parce que je pense qu'il faut
laisser entendre la population russe que
ce n'est pas la vérité que l'Occident
n'est pas contre les Russes en général
contre la société civile en général
qu'il peut y avoir qui aurait pu y avoir
d'autres choix politiques qui étaient
faits c'est pour parce qu'on veut faire
un temps de cette petite musique et
qu'on veut pas abandonner les Russes
soit qui sont encore dans le pays mais
qui vivent un peu cachés qui cachent
leurs opinions soit tous ceux qui sont
en exil leur faire comprendre que on est
là pour garder ce lien et c'est pour ça
que j'ai pris la présidence de ce groupe
sur la Russie parce que finalement il
faut maintenir un lien avec la société
civile il faut maintenir l'idée que un
autre avenir est possible et je j'en
profite aussi pour dire ça ça nous
permet d'entendre aussi quelques voies
dissidentes se préoccuper bien sûr des
sortes des opposants qui sont en prison
donc justement je voulais revenir cette
situation des prisonniers russes on le
sait Alexa
emprisonné depuis maintenant février
2022 depuis plus d'un an le 17 avril
tout est récemment c'est un autre plot
opposant Vladimir karamozera des donc il
était qualifié de seconde opposant après
Alexa
à Vladimir Poutine qui a été condamné à
25 ans de prison le Parlement européen a
voté également récemment ça libération
avec Alexa Navalny que sait-on de leurs
conditions de détention et est-ce que
c'est c'est emprisonnement vous vous
inquiète en tant que président du groupe
France Russie la situation est très
préoccupante parce que les deux navanni
comme karamuza sont en mauvaise santé
donc car amourza avait été comme Navali
empoisonnée dans le passé il avait
récupéré plus ou moins et là forcément
en prison il n'a pas les traitements
dont il faudrait qu'il dispose et sa
santé se dégrade c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont reporté son son procès qui a eu
finalement lieu qui a été confirmé la
semaine dernière où il y a une dizaine
de jours le con à 25 ans de prison
Navali on sait très bien ce qui lui est
arrivé étant ayez ayant été empoisonné
et sauvé de xtremis en Allemagne mais
retourner en Russie parce que ce sont
des opposants qui qui continuent de
croire que ils ne peuvent mener leur
combat que depuis l'intérieur donc ils
sont très courageux mais ils payent le
prix très très fort et finalement il y a
ils ne sont pas les seuls il y a FC il y
a il y a Chine qui comme Vladimir
karamoza était un
je dirais un quelqu'un qui était associé
à Boris namsov et Boris namsov qui était
l'opposition la plus crédible à Poutine
au moment des des émeutes de 2011 2012 a
été tué a été tué sur le pont face au
Kremlin donc soit ils sont en prison les
opposants soit soit ils sont morts donc
je pense qu'ils ont besoin de notre
soutien c'est pour ça que j'ai rencontré
la l'épouse de
aussi de façon sémantique c'est pas la
même chose la défense de l'Europe elle
appartient à l'OTAN donc compatriotes
ont peut-être du mal à le comprendre
mais dans les traités l'Alliance et là
pour que les Américains nous viennent en
aide éventuellement si on a un souci et
entre allier avec avec la
Grande-Bretagne aussi et d'autres pays
ont pu se résister c'était une alliance
effectivement qui était tournée vers
d'éventuelles agressions de l'ancien
Pacte de Varsovie bien sûr les choses
ont évolué et c'est vrai qu'à un moment
donné l'OTAN c'est d'éliter d'où la
phrase du président Macron et on peut
dire qu'à ce moment-là avec le président
Trump la mort cérébrale de l'OTAN
n'était pas une contre-vérité bien sûr
que ce conflit en Ukraine a revivifié
revigoré l'alliance au temps et bien sûr
que l'on voit qu'elle a joué pleinement
son rôle puisque les ailes américains
sont particulièrement mobilisés en
soutien Ukraine mais tous les pays aussi
vu la situation par rapport à la Chine
absolument mais ils ont voilà ils ont
plusieurs fer au feu aussi les
Américains c'est pour ça qu'il faut
quand même continuer sur la voie de
l'autonomie stratégique en Europe
100% des Américains c'est ça l'idée
exactement mais c'est à dire que déjà il
faut que les armées européennes
se consolide aussi c'est pas l'armure
européenne je parle les armées les
différents pays européens et c'est ce
qu'on voit en face il y a une phase de
réarmement c'est-à-dire que la France
nous dès 2017 on était déjà en train de
réinvestir ce qui n'était pas le cas des
Allemands ce qui n'était pas le cas de
nombre de pays
en Europe en ce moment c'est l'effort il
y a un effort de guerre qui est énorme
et c'est important pour contribuer déjà
à l'OTAN l'OTAN c'est quoi c'est la
réunion de plusieurs armées dont des
armées européennes aujourd'hui vous avez
22 pays européens sur 31 qui sont de
l'OTAN donc le pilier européen il faut
le consolider il faut le consolider sur
le plan des capacités mais aussi le
musclé peut-être un petit peu
politiquement en se disant à la Pologne
l'armée polonaise qui se développe
énormément armée allemande aussi qui qui
a lancé un grand plan de modernisation
voilà mais l'armée polonaise
effectivement aspire être la première
armée terrestre d'Europe à court terme
et alors moi je dirais que tout ça c'est
favorable à la défense collective de
l'Europe mais c'est pas forcément
favorable à l'Europe de la défense parce
que dans la notion d'Europe de la
défense il y a notre industrie aussi il
y a nos compétences nous savoir faire
nos technologies il y a tout tout ce qui
est toutes les approvisionnements qui
sont critiques aussi tout ce qui fait la
souveraineté que l'on doit avoir en
Europe sinon nous ne serons que
tributaires des armements achetés soit
effectivement aux États-Unis soit en
Israël soit en Corée puisque la Pologne
vient d'acheter aussi des chars en Corée
et ça c'est pas l'avenir dont nous
voulons si nous voulons avoir une
capacité de décision autonomie il faut
que nous ayons nos propres services de
renseignement comme j'ai dit nos propres
satellites qui vont avoir une vision la
plus globale possible il faut aussi que
nous ayons nos propres industries avec
avec des technologies que nous
maîtriserons de A à Z parce que si
jamais les États-Unis étaient engagés
dans un autre effort de guerre un peu
plus tard un peu plus loin
par exemple dans le Pacifique il
servirait leur armée en premier et là
l'Europe se retrouverait
prise au dépourvu merci beaucoup
Nathalie d'avoir été avec nous dans le
livre de politique je rappelle donc que
vous êtes député renaissance de la
sixième circonscription des Yvelines
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de
l'hebdo-politique sur Radio sensation et
sur TV 78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
de politique